hi I'm Erik Bosse and bird box on
Netflix left us with quite a few
questions like can a movie about people
being tricked into killing themselves
actually trick people into doing in real
life hope not beyond the various
interpretations of bird box what
interests me the most is the mystery of
the monsters themselves like what are
they exactly how do they work what do
they look like are the birds in on it
they always are
now I'm looking around I can't really
find a good complete answer anywhere so
I'm going to do my best to explain the
truth of these monsters and their origin
swirler warning if you haven't seen bird
box yet so first off what are the
monsters we never actually see them in
their form in this movie aside from you
know some shadows and floating leaves
wrestling branches etc but in the
opening minutes we do learn the basics
looking at the monsters drives people to
commit suicide mass suicides began in
Romania and then spread through Europe
and Russia and the rest of the world now
the mass suicides are not pathological
or viral meaning that they're not caused
by a virus or bacteria some kind of
epidemic or biological warfare no
they're creatures and these creatures
appear to be autonomous like they're not
controlled by any hive mind where the
consciousness of one creature is linked
back to a central node making them all
part of one giant force of nature so no
this doesn't like the movie the
happening where I guess mother nature
was the real enemy there or a real hero
or other movies with alien drones all
connected back to a mothership now a
little into the movie Charlie a doomsday
conspiracy theorist gives us his take
you got world religion mythology there's
full of mentions of demons Oh spirit
creatures the entity that takes on a
form of your worst fears or deepest
sadness or your greatest loss now we're
not meant to take Charlie literally
because clearly these things don't fit
neatly in any folklore explanation but
Charlie is to this movie what the
character Dustin is and stranger things
a hilarious super nerd who uses his
reference base to try to explain the
unexplainable and just like Dungeons &
Dragons creatures ended up being not the
worst guide to the demagogue in and the
mind player Charlie is also here to help
us with references to demons from
various world religions all gained from
his extensive research from Wikipedia he
cites a common aah and daiva
both from Zoroastrian mythology of
ancient Mesopotamia the alchemy na is an
evil spirit that seduces humans into
giving in to their darker impulses the
daiva is a force of chaos and disorder
he also mentions
got a Christian occult demon mentioned
in the Gremory of Pope Honorius and the
secrets of Solomon he's a character who
opens all walks the who lie Jing is a
nine-tailed fox spirit from Chinese
mythology that can take human form they
could be good or bad and a puka is from
Celtic folklore a trickster demon who
often takes the form of a rabbit hookahs
have actually shown up in pop culture in
the play in the film Harvey possibly in
Donnie Darko I don't know if that thing
was technically a puka now this whole
idea of a shape-shifting demon that
takes the form of your greatest fear
it's come up again and again in pop
culture as well like penny wise and
Stephen King's it embodies one's fear
depending on who's looking at him the
Boggart and Harry Potter of course and
the demon in the movie it follows
actually works very similarly it's
something whose true form we never
actually see it shape shifts into
whatever form will help get closer to
its prey but these monsters and bird box
aren't exactly the supernatural demons
that Charlie describes like they have
shadows which means they must block
sunlight they have mass and weight they
move leaves and branches triggering car
motion sensors they have some strength
because they seem to be able to nudge
their car a little bit and they can lift
up some of girl's hair they just can't
directly harm you like they can't open
doors or break through walls they can't
blow you to death or bite you or cut you
they could only get inside your head
and compel you to look at them and then
you'll kill yourself this trigger takes
a visual form of the victims eyes
deforming they become tears stricken and
bloodshot dilation of the pupils so when
we see Mallory the kids running from
them in the woods they weren't really
running from physical danger they're
just running from the sounds that these
creatures use to influence them not
today Satan but for the characters who
do see these monsters what do they see
remember Charlie described it to us as
an entity that takes the form of your
worst fears your deepest sadness or your
greatest loss so when Mallory's sister
just sees it she looks at it and gasps
oh my god what is that
and then she goes into this trance in
her case I'm assuming this could be her
worst fear her initial reaction just
seems terrified
shortly after this when Douglass's wife
Lydia sees it we hear a woman's voice
whisper and she goes into a trance
saying mom please don't go before she
sits in a fiery car presumably her
mother whom Douglas said died years
earlier was Lydia's greatest loss later
in the movie when Olympia sees the
monster she becomes
it's fixed and she says you're not so
bad now in her case I'm wondering if the
monsters taking the form of her greatest
sadness like maybe being alone
and toward the end of the movie when Tom
sees it listen closely the whispers that
he hear it's hard to make it out but it
sounds kind of like the voice of Mallory
making me think that what he sees is his
greatest fear is greatest sadness the
image of Mallory and the kids dying
which might explain why he's able to
resist a bit longer to kill that gang
member now according to the film's crew
one deleted scene was going to show us
what the creatures look like in a
nightmare sequence with Mallory Sager
Bullock described it as a green man with
a horrific baby face it was snake-like
see when they filmed it she told the
crew to surprise her with this monster
and it ended up making her laugh she
called it a long fat baby growling at
her now of course this long fat green
baby could have been a projection that
Mallory sees like a metaphorical
embodiment of her fear of motherhood oh
yeah I'm very glad we didn't see it now
another possible glimpse of the monster
appeared in sketches by Gary the
newcomer who betrays a group we learn
after this that he is probably one of
the mentally ill patients who had seen
one of the creatures we could see how
his eyes have been affected but he
considers them to be beautiful his
drawings show various creepy forms some
of which seem inspired by HP Lovecraft
he was author who created Kulu a massive
looming cosmic demon who drives it's
observers mad but again these drawings
only depict what Gary saw and it brings
us to another big question why can some
people see the monsters without turnin
suicidal when they first meet Gary he
tells them that escaped inmates from
Northwood mental institution for the
criminally insane forced people's eyes
open they didn't need blindfolds they
wanted to see they were happy they were
so glad
then they said everyone needed to see a
gort's Gary ends up being one of these
guys along with the man who waited out
to Mallory's boat earlier Charley's
grocery store coworker fish fingers
who's an ex-con that Charlie called a
bit crazy
he ended up forcing Charlie to look at
the monster and of course the marauding
gang that they run into later the
conclusion were meant to draw is that
assuming the monsters take the form of
your worst fear deepest sadness or
greatest loss maybe people have already
suffered their worst fear sadnesses and
losses are unaffected it's a potentially
problematic idea but I guess bird box is
suggesting that what is already broken
cannot be broken again and perhaps by
seeing their darkest demons break other
people that becomes a sort of validation
for the criminally insane like they sort
of become the one-eyed men in the land
of the blind I finally the rest of the
world recognizes my demons as real and
in these people's eyes it makes the
monsters sort of their salvation that's
what makes them beautiful so we know
what these people want but what about
the monsters themselves is their end
goal charlie interprets these creatures
as demons bringing about the apocalypse
and I suppose that could be
extraterrestrial or interdimensional
beings with telepathic powers they need
to destabilize him in society and
exterminate us and it is interesting
that they were first spotted in Romania
of all places one of the regions
associated with vampire folklore
vampires like these creatures cannot
enter homes without invitation they can
be invisible they could take multiple
forms they sparkle in the sunlight
forget that last one but these monsters
and bird locks don't appear to want
earth for resources or colonization like
their movement is a little mindless and
wandering they're not tactical at all
like you would think they would try to
whisper through the walls of the
suburban house to trick the humans and
opening a door or a window rather than
just you know sitting there and waiting
for someone to accidentally see them I
would say they really are more of a
force of nature than like predators with
agendas and speaking of nature this
whole idea of mass suicides reminded me
of the lemmings
you know those Norwegian rodents whom
for years people mistakenly believed
commit mass suicide by running off
cliffs into the ocean and drowning but
it's a big misconception lemmings don't
intentionally commit suicide see when
they're overpopulated some lemmings will
follow biological urges to migrate by
swimming to nearby unoccupied land and
unfortunately some jump into the open
ocean by mistake
accidentally drowned it's very sad but
what if these monsters are kind of the
same thing like maybe they're not new
arrivals to earth maybe they're just
biological forces that have always been
here floating around us since the dawn
of time some select individuals could
have already witnessed them but maybe
for the rest of us only when the human
species reached a brink of
overpopulation did these migratory
instincts present themselves in monster
form but instead of us migrating to a
new island or a peninsula across the
fjord our instincts drive us to migrate
to the other side of existence
propelling us in front of traffic we're
out of windows just another
interpretation for you to keep in mind
but here's my question for you what do
you think each character actually saw
when they looked at the monster for
example do you think it's possible that
Jess's WTF vision was actually her
sister Mallory dead alone her child
never born and that's why she gives her
that second look after the car accident
and she steps to further the bus like
what she's seen there with Sandra
Bullock on the ground is her worst fear
come to pass comment down below with
your thoughts and follow me rock stars
on Twitter at new rockstars following me
on Twitter and Instagram at leave us and
subscribed a new rock stars for
breakdowns of everything you love Game
of Thrones we do horror films stranger
things we really covered all here
to continue to a high-fat diet and get
little to no exercise it's still suicide
it's just slower